Hello, and welcome back to CZsWorld.
Today we’re gonna be talking about the new
pre-roll ad for the Nun.
But you might want to turn your volume down
because *SCREAM*.
OK, I’m sorry.
I’m sorry.
I had to.
People are losing their minds right now over
this YouTube pre-roll ad for The Nun.
I assume you’ve probably seen it if you’re
watching this video, but if not, it looks
like this.
And this was brought to my attention by a
tweet going viral right now by a user named
apple, who says:
WARNING!
If you see an ad on youtube with the volume
sign being turned down and nothing else, ITS
A JUMPSCARE for the new NUN movie coming out.
i advise you look away and/or turn down the
volume if you have anxiety or just straight
up dislike jumpscares, pls rt to save a life
And that tweet has amassed over 100,000 retweets
in just 24 hours.
There are articles being written about this
and people are actually calling for YouTube
to take down the ad.
To which I have to say -- apple and whoever
else is tweeting about this right now.
Why you gotta go and ruin the fun for everyone,
like me, who hasn’t seen the ad yet and
would have enjoyed that little scare.
I mean people are acting like this is something
like the public needs to be aware of.
It’s not like the Nun comes out of your
screen and punches you in the face.
It’s a loud noise, not a safety hazard.
And don’t you dare call for this ad to be
taken down.
We just got through the Adpocalypse, and it’s
hard enough for horror creators, like myself,
to earn a living because many brands no longer
consider horror content to be “safe” to
advertise on.
So now we finally have an ad that is tailor
made, to run in front of horror channels,
and you are not going to take that away from
us, just so that you don’t get startled
for two seconds.
Not to mention, that as long as you have ad
personalization on in your Google settings,
which…
I mean why would you not, I mean if you have
to see ads, you might as well see ones that
are relevant to your interests, but if you
have this on, and you don’t like horror
movies, you probably won’t see the ad anyways.
My ads are personalized to include horror
and I still haven’t seen this come up.
And to be honest, as much as I love the concept
of this ad, and it reminds me of the classic
YouTube screamer videos from the mid 2000s
that you never really see anymore… this
one’s not really fooling anybody.
First of all, it uses the Mac OS volume icon.
And I don’t know, maybe there’s a different
version of the ad for Android or Windows,
but unless you’re on Mac, and you’re browsing
full screen so that the icon is actually centered
on screen, you’re probably not going to
fall for it.
But look at some of these responses.
“they need to display a warning before such
ads!!!! i cannot stand watching or even listening
to anything related to the horror genre, my
heart’s too fragile to take it and my mind
effs up bad & it ends up haunting me for the
rest of my life!!!!”
Well no, if you put a warning, that completely
ruins it.
The point of the ad is to catch you off guard
to get your attention.
It’s marketing 101.
“I WATCHED IT MUTED AND IM STILL ON THE
VERGE OF TEARS”.
Are we really that soft now that people are
in tears over a 6 second advert?
I mean, I’m so sick of everything being
watered down for my spineless excuse of a
generation.
Everything is constantly complained about
to the point that those of us with common
sense can’t have nice things when Therese
here cannot handle the sight of a fictional
character.
“Great, I am already having anxiety from
knowing this exists.
@YouTube would you please revise this add?
It really isn't costumer friendly”
Well actually, the Nun costume is very well
done.
In my opinion the costumers did a great job.
But if you feel like this ad is giving you
too much anxiety, I’d recommend you crawl
back into the womb from which you came from
which you came from, because you’re not
quite ready for the real world yet.
“I won't be watching YouTube videos for
a while then , I hate jumpscares”
This is interesting because usually when someone
says they hate jumpscares, it’s because
a movie relies on jumpscares too much and
doesn’t build that suspense that you need
for a jumpscare to have a good payoff.
Personally I really like jumpscares when they’re
done well, and in the context of this ad,
it uses the volume icon to throw off the viewer,
so if the prerequisites of being on a Mac
and being full screen are met, I think it’s
a clever advert.
But, it is a bit random theming wise… like
what do computers have to do with a Romanian
Nun Demon?
It would have actually fit better for a horror
movie about technology like Unfriended or
Friend Request… or…
Scary...
Friend...
Internet...
Movie……...?
And it looks like before I even had the chance
to finish up this video and post it, YouTube
has already gone ahead and taken down the
ad.
And they do point to this article on their
ad policy where they do have rules against
violent and shocking ads in content.
Including promotions that are likely to shock
or scare.
But then they say what they consider to be
shocking factors in ads are.
Whether the video shows scenes containing
violent and/or graphic imagery that can be
shocking or disturbing to viewers
Whether the video shows the graphic aftermath
of a violent act
Whether the shots of violence or gore are
the focal point of the scene in the video
And whether the violence contained in the
video is realistic when posted in a dramatic
context
And they also go on to say that other factors
include the camera angle and focus, and the
clarity of the images in the video
So it looks like this Nun ad doesn't technically
have of these factors that they consider to
be shocking.
But I'm sure we'll never hear a statement
on it.
And my advertiser revenue will go down as
a result of this.
So this is the perfect opportunity to say
to check out my merch store and maybe pick
up an item or two to support the channel.
But if you are one of those people whose life
was not ruined by this ad, then drop me a
like on this video.
I’m genuinely curious to see what the like
to dislike ratio comes out to on this one.
And remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for
more great horror content every week, ring
that deathbell for notifications… you know
what?
Ring that thing loud enough to startle some
complainer on the internet, and I’ll see
you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.